[Music]
in birth consent news okay submitted by
fresh coffee
a man wants to sue his parents for
giving birth to him without consent I
love it I was never even born I didn't
want to be he's dirty right man yeah oh
is he trying to like prove a point he's
twenty-seven anti-nato esteeming he's
got he's trolling it sounds like someone
trolling deeper to you in awesome if
it's a troll he's trolling he's rockin I
think it's a little better he loves his
parents he supports his parents but he's
chewing on stew
but he's suing because they did not his
convinced what is he suing it's
hilarious his parents are lawyers
oh yeah he's being a [ __ ] this sounds
like he's like someone like got into an
argument at the dinner table and they
were just trying to try to prove a point
like well bit I'm gonna [ __ ] sue you
then yeah so his name is Raphael Samuel
he's 27
- first names really weird he's from
Mumbai well and yep so on Facebook he
described himself as anti needleless so
he believes that it's morally wrong for
people to procreate so he says that pro
a general yes in general he says
procreation is a root of all evil stop
having babies
oh yeah it's from India like
overpopulated is this happening in India
like the lawsuit and everything or he's
just from Mumbai oh they're like
children are entitled
oh really I thought giving birth to and
another being without its consent and
forcing it to work and pay bills for
your pleasure is a definition of
entitled this other one look at this guy
good period puts the towels above its
wants and needs but the child itself is
a want of the parent it is parents are
hypocrites she's not wrong
yeah look this is a meme he's meaning
doing that video Indian Jesus over here
yeah so he drank some buses and a fake
beard and so he posted a video this is
gotta be comedy this guy's gotta beat
wrong yeah he posted a video answering
all these questions that a lot of people
are asking him if you serious though
it's even better than it is better than
colors he chose he was sitting there
like what proves the most points kink or
yellow yeah so he's saying that having
children is he compares it to kidnapping
and slavery mm-hmm
yeah so anyway this video we just
condensed it to a couple of his answers
here we go enjoy by having us speak or
the certain happiness the happiness or
interview were a mistake either ways we
were not asked and it is not also it's
not even possible to ask a child whether
they get this looks so all I mean by no
consent is that you realize that you are
sure and you do not worry appearance
anything and it was not your decision
something that is not your decision you
cannot be responsible for and therefore
you do not have to be responsible to
your parents what I want to tell all
children and parents I want to tell
children that your parents do you do
anything for them okay you will not come
you to come under their blackmail we do
not need to declare if you don't want if
you feel like to it and I want to tell
parents that you don't own your children
you do not own every decision they make
we are individuals not your investments
Tyga's a [ __ ] individual you monsters
dude I love the music to me she the
first child in this group why we know
she's a monster okay I'm not gonna you
guys right now cuz you can so raise this
kid with individuality like she has for
me right yeah and you should for Mike
well we asked I cut who wants to come
into his world and in his sonogram you
did the middle finger and I was like
well [ __ ] you to go now [ __ ] you back
you're coming out buddy we're pulling
you out
well actually is
my hands in there like two months I just
how you feelin Geo was that cool yeah
it's great how are ya yeah get that
little booger please yes Lana on his
Facebook page he posted this Stephen
would you like to do this take care
mother speaks I'm rad fields mother this
is my responsible recent upheaval
my son has created I must admire my
son's temerity to want to take his
parents to court knowing both of us are
lawyers
if frankly it wasn't I do well he knows
more words than I do
temerity she's aware if Rafael could
come up with a rational explanation as
to how we could have sought his consent
to be born I will accept my fault so
there all the both gaming each other
this is great
the media has focused on a sliver of
what Raphael believes in his belief in
antinatalism is concerned for the burden
on earth's resources due to needless
life his sensitivity towards the pain
experienced unwittingly by children
while growing up and so much more has
been ruefully forgotten I'm very happy
that my son has grown up into a fearless
independent thinking young man he is
sure to find his path to happiness
kavita corn odd Samuel dude I feel like
there are really smart people that are
cranking average people because people
will pluck and pick this up and go oh my
god can you believe this yes it's kids
ooh what an ungrateful piece of [ __ ] or
another 30 year old that's like oh my
God he's Spock what I hate my parents
yeah I didn't know how to formulate
sentences but he took the words right
out of my mouth
they're suing the National Enquirer
reader people yeah of their country I
know they're playing a big [ __ ] prank
I love it I love it was a family prank -
I don't know how it started like I want
to I want to be at the dinner table that
this like argument started at I don't
want to stop where consent can be
decreed right like like because that
seems to be the delusion it started with
like like oh do the dishes like just
something really where's your girlfriend
yeah and then it just went down the list
of things and clothes like I don't have
consent for that or this or this or this
and you didn't have consent to have me
right just like work its way all the way
down well it goes all the way to the
like the kids movie thing of like I
never asked to be born which isn't like
half of every kids movie ever
yeah slams the door runs away from me
yeah
so deal I bear more towards the serious
because like like his mom said and that
Facebook thing he's more focused on how
they want people to stop making kids so
this is what his Facebook page yeah
overpopulated so India I mean sorry his
Facebook page is called child free India
and so I feel like he's the biggest
troll in the world should we continue to
bring you my talk it sounds like you are
speaking some other like should we
continue to bring more children in this
world and accelerate the process of
environmental and social degradation do
you think existence is pain and not
bringing a child into this world is a
guaranteed way to avoid unnecessary
suffering to the child we are a group of
people who have decided not to reproduce
we are child free Indians so they're
also saying that they don't want to
impose their beliefs on anyone but more
people need to consider why having a
child in the world right now is not
right so this is in order to so having
children is a strain on earth's
resources and avoiding procreation for
environmental reasons is something that
everyone should consider these people
always cracked me up because it's like
okay if humanity does not exist on the
earth anymore they get off on the idea
that like earth is no longer scourged by
us but I'm like you look at cows watch
it they're all [ __ ] up everything
here like in the ocean there's pollution
from [ __ ] fish and [ __ ] but didn't
tip that pollution gets eaten up by
their little ecosystem I just love all
of it I love all of it I think it's a
terrible point no like I definitely
think like oh like we could afford to
have less kids and stuff like in the
world but like to the explain though
because it's it's offering an extreme as
like a different point of like looking
at it yeah that's what kind of as a joke
that's why I love these people of the
extreme cuz it's always they are gonna
go too far they're gonna take their
belief too far it's it's like take a
good idea
and then run it off a [ __ ] cliff what
I want to see them as all this whole
group if they're like okay we're all for
this child free India I want to see this
group of people all I could pull the
trigger together like count of three
we're going to blow up or nutsacks three
two or the one fellows right because
they're also taking resources yeah [ __ ]
you know they got garbage nuts at and
the brain they poop four hundred pounds
a year or whatever it is they want other
people to do that not themselves though
that's the same thing yeah they're like
everybody else do it but I don't have to
let me on yes imagine these guys kids
right he says now I feel like he's a lot
of years all to his mind you know how
like a lot of country like Japan Korea
even us we're not repopulating as much
as the baby boomer generation yeah not
all East LA is yeah you're right because
like China and India is still going and
then like I think Congo or one of the
African countries or they're about to go
pretty big too so it's like the balance
is shifting so I mean I don't know if
we're projected to grow that fast but
there is what do you call it a theory
about where population is supposed to
take like start tapering off down again
yeah like we're gonna hit this peak and
then we're just naturally as a species
like start going down by 2040 like
they're saying both Japan and Korea
would be like very very small yeah
that's why they're doing my ad campaigns
like make babies and successfully and
you turned out if people having kids
they got too efficient I think it's like
overpopulation in a concentrated area
yeah cuz Tokyo is like 20 million people
it's the most populated city on earth
and then the second most populated was
Osaka so there's two most populated
cities in Japan but then I mean I don't
know like you get that many people in
one little area you're gonna cause all
this like what do you call it what it's
like the ash it's like mind yeah yeah
we're we're the hive is like oh there's
too many [ __ ] people so we don't need
a mage yeah
I think there's too many people in
[ __ ] la was about to say we got to
get on that in LA I can't right I'm I'm
not for population control no I'm moving
here though population control Vegas
that's what I'm saying
nice house dude my friends live in Vegas
and they don't even know what the [ __ ]
traffic is anymore they're like what are
you talking about cuz what we deal with
compared to with a deal with Ain't
Nothing
traffic on the strip though sorry I
don't want to destroy the magic of Vegas
either like I want to go there and be
excited like oh yeah Hawaii like I go
there's a magic ability that's true cuz
people always go oh I can't wait till I
move to LA and they go back it's like
when you go to Hollywood you're just
like Oh get the [ __ ] it's like coming
here it takes me an hour and a half
leaving at night 20 minutes
city bro so another one of those things
on Facebook it says why should I suffer
why must I be stuck in traffic why must
I work why must they face wars why must
they feel pain and depression why should
I do anything when I don't want too many
questions
one answer someone had you for their
pleasure really got him there yeah do
you get that much pleasure out of a kid
you do right you seem to I love Tyga
yeah and you do you seem to yeah wait so
he's saying if if you have a kid was
born out of pleasure it's not okay its
sinister its sinister so if kid is born
out of rape which is not pleasurable at
all that's okay
he wants more rape kits I don't think
that that's his point but I could be
wrong and I don't want speak for him so
I'm trying to play with his logic right
yes I'm like pleasure baby he's like no
pleasure baby not so he did say that
some people are born by mistake he did
what he said thing no no his whole thing
was I didn't think about you as the baby
didn't ask to be born
so you
as the person that was born should not
be obligated to do anything your parents
want because they didn't ask for your
permission that's a social you came
about I wish outer he said all that he
said kids rule we should put soda in the
water fountains oh yeah
[Music]
you